thank you for thank you thank you very
much I appreciate it so nice and I'm
thrilled to be here tonight at the very
first and as the very first president to
address this incredible group of people
I have a lot of friends in the audience
there are incredible people and I'd also
like to thank the susan b anthony list
chairwoman jane abraham and her husband
the honorable spence abraham for hosting
this beautiful gala thank you both thank
you very much thank you very much
beautiful job and we're also very glad
to be joined by many wonderful members
of congress including the legend from
louisiana very brave guy steve skalise
first
[Applause]
I save so I was going to ask all members
of Congress to stand but there's a short
list should I just we have to do this
right they're fighting for you all the
time right don't you think all right
you have Steve Steve stand do you have
no problem standing this guy's in better
shape than all of us Kevin Brady where's
Kevin
what a man he is thank you thank you
Kevin Steve Daines Steve Daines hi Steve
thank you Steve
great where's Roger wicker Roger Roger
right you know the problem with this
Roger
we're guaranteed to leave a few out and
they'll never speak to me again but
that's okay we'll have you stand if I
did that a man who has been so
incredible on television to me Andy
Biggs congressman Andy Biggs where's
Andy thank you Andy now I don't have to
call you and thank you thank you Andy
Marcia Blackburn Marcia good luck
will hopefully be our next senator from
the great great great state of Tennessee
good and I just saw some great numbers
in you by the way where Steve Sharat
where Steve Steve Steve Steve
how will you Steve Ben help Kevin Cramer
who's leading he's leading in his Senate
race Kevin where's Kevin Kevin you're
leading you know we have a lot of people
that are leading these races and a
number just came down from Reuters you
know we were a few months ago 16 down in
the generic Paul whatever that's
supposed to mean cuz nobody really knows
what it means but all I know is we were
16 down
Reuters just came out two hours ago and
we're one up that's a big difference
and they say that to win we have to be
like if we're six down we're in okay
shape well we're one up that's pretty
good so that's for the senators and for
the congressmen and women so that's it
but you're doing fantastic kept Sean
Duffy where's Sean where's Sean
[Applause]
Thank You Sean great job
Ron Estes Ron thank you Ron Jeff
Fortenberry
Jeff thank you Jeff good job a friend of
mine for a long time Virginia Foxx
Virginia thanks Virginia representative
and mrs. Greg okay we're Susan Susan GN
forte where is he
boy he is a good he is a good campaigner
great job great job thank you Susan
representative and mrs. Andy you know
they wrote this out they said and mrs.
Andy and Nicole so what's just gonna say
it Andy and Nicole Harris stand up
please thank you great thank you
a man who is I hope he's here because
he's so busy but a man who is a true
champion NCAA champion for numerous
years like I'm not sure he ever lost a
match somebody said he's like 141 and
won but that's not bad Jim Jordan where
is he Jim Jordan where's Jim
he is thanks Jim thanks great champion
Mike Kelly I watched him the other day
he was debating Maxine Waters that was
not a close to that that was not a close
debate Mike they should all be so easy
right Mike Congressman Steve King
do you think Steve is conservative
enough where's Steve hi Steve
is Steve conservative enough folks I
don't you don't get more conservative
than Steve right thank you Steve
Congressman Joe Lesko and Debbie missus
Lesko where are you thank you folks
Thank You Debbie thank you dan Lipinski
thanks tucker carlson washington the
regularly scheduled show will start in
just a minute but we're gonna continue
listening to the president at the
campaign for life and gala here in
Washington oh this man central casting i
watch him all the time don't know him
well but I'll get to know him John
Rutherford where is John central casting
great job John he's always defending me
actually most of you are always
defending me in that cell phone and from
my neck of the woods
Claudia Teddy Thank You Claudia thank
you
and for those many that I've left out
I'm sorry but I said give me a totally
complete list and I will call you
tomorrow and I will apologize personally
all right but every day between now and
November we must work together to elect
more lawmakers who share our values
cherish our heritage and proudly stand
for life
and that is a great group of people I
introduced I can tell you that we're
also glad to be joined by a beloved
member of my administration a true
fighter for faith and family and your
2018 distinguished leader
Kellyanne Conway Kelly yeah what a job
what a job she's done
[Applause]
she is some fighter she'll do the shows
that nobody else dares go near she'll
just I'll say do this one or that one no
problem sir
others say sir do you think I could take
a pass please I beg you please
great going Kellyanne thank you what a
help what a help
finally to all of the friends activists
and supporters of the life movement who
are here this evening so many this was a
record crowd your hard work helped us to
achieve this historic victory our
historic victory one of the great
victories of all time in politics that
beautiful beautiful evening November
remember that evening could it have been
wobbling
[Applause]
2016 that November 8th 2016 on the other
side you had some very unhappy campers I
get to watch they were not happy they
were going to have a big beautiful party
didn't turn out to be such a good
now for the first time since roe v wade
america has a pro-life president a
pro-life vice president a pro-life House
of Representative and 25 pro-life
Republican state capitals that is pretty
good that is pretty good Wow
that is pretty good when I ran for
office I pledged to stand for life and
as president that's exactly what I've
done and I have kept my promise and I
think everybody here understands that
follow one of my very first acts as
president was to reinstate the Mexico
City policy to prevent taxpayer dollars
from funding abortion centers overseas
[Applause]
it's a little reminiscent of Ronald
Reagan a few months later with Marjorie
in the Oval Office he was sitting there
with us and she stood then and signed
legislation to overturn the rule that
for states to fund abortion providers
with taxpayer dollars Marjorie was there
with them
we've appointed a record number of
judges who will defend our Constitution
and interpret the law as written and
we're putting onto the bench a record
number of judges and in a short period
of time we were going to have and are
going to have probably the all-time
record for the appointment of judges and
I'm very excited about that my
administration is also taken bold action
to protect religious liberty and today
we are making another historic
announcement for decades American
taxpayers have been wrongfully forced to
subsidize the abortion industry through
title 10 federal funding so today we
have kept another promise my
administration has proposed a new rule
to prohibit title 10 funding from going
to any clinic that performs abortions
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much we're also seeking
passage of the 20-week abortion bill
which would end painful late term
abortions nationwide the house just
passed the bill but Democrats in the
Senate are doing everything within their
power to block it although some are
actually on our side but they are
working overtime to block it so the
story is 18 midterms we need Republicans
and that will happen on this issue like
so many other issues the Democratic
Party is far outside the American
mainstream far outside the United States
is one of only seven countries in the
world to allow elective abortions after
20 weeks when unborn babies can truly
feel the pain yet Democratic senators
like John tester Heidi Heitkamp Claire
McCaskill debbie Stabenow all voted
against the 20-week bill and in favor of
late term abortion gotta get out and
vote we're nine votes away from passing
the 20-week abortion bill in the Senate
so we have to get them out there the
Democratic senators are up for
reelection
in ten states that I won by a lot and I
think we're doing very well we have some
of those folks that are running right
now and they're doing very very well
have a big big surprise in six months
big beautiful surprise
if we work hard between now and November
every one of these states can be flipped
to a senator who shares our values and
votes our agenda Democrats like to
campaign as moderates at election time
but when they go to Washington they
always vote for the radical Pelosi
agenda down the line can you imagine
having Nancy Pelosi as the Speaker of
the House can you imagine no can you
imagine that's why we're putting in
place a massive campaign for a midterm
victory this November we will need to
elect more members of Congress who will
protect life support our military secure
our borders and grow our economy and
continue making America great again
[Applause]
while Democrats in Washington are
resisting progress my administration is
delivering progress for hardworking
Americans each and every day and we're
doing some job since the election we
have created more than 3.3 million new
jobs and if I would have said that prior
to the election those people back there
you know who that is right that's called
the fake news fake news they would have
said what a ridiculous statement he's
saying he's going to project 3.3 million
new jobs how ridiculous is that well
guess what we did it fake news
something I'm very proud of
african-american unemployment is at the
lowest level in history
[Applause]
[Applause]
hispanic unemployment is likewise at the
lowest level in history women
unemployment is at the lowest level in
19 years and something you haven't heard
for 21 years wages are rising at the
fastest pace in more than time they said
21
I did hear 19 I have to be very accurate
with these folks let's put it this way
wages are rising at a very fast level
very far got to be very careful you know
when you say something if it's like a
little off if I was off by a week and a
half it's a headline tomorrow we got him
now
something very important small business
optimism is the highest that it's ever
been ever recorded
and our great House Ways and Means
chairman Kevin Brady joins us tonight
has done an incredible job thank you
Kevin
with his leadership Republicans passed
the biggest tax cut and reform in
American history and we doubled the
child tax credit
[Applause]
and we're going to be with Kevin and the
entire group we're going to be
submitting additional tax cuts sometime
prior to November it's going to be
something very special you see what it's
done for the country it's gonna be
something very very special
and by the way Nancy Pelosi and the
group
you heard her the other day she wants to
raise your taxes they want to get rid of
the tax cut bill and raise your taxes
somehow I don't think that plays well
but you never know right
once they raise your taxes and my
presidential budget was the first in
history to include a proposal for
nationwide paid family leave good Steve
good we want to honor the invaluable
time parents spend with their newborn
children on foreign affairs you've been
reading a lot about foreign affairs
we're getting very high marks and
foreign affairs actually we are as a
country respected again it's been a long
time
because we've restored American strength
and confidence our military and we just
had it approved seven hundred billion
dollars its historic funding for our
great military seven hundred billion
dollars and we have left the horrible
one-sided miserable Iran deal it's gone
[Applause]
one of the worst deals ever negotiated
we get nothing we get nothing we've
moved our embassy to Jerusalem
[Applause]
thank you
and we are renegotiating trade deals to
bring jobs and wealth back home to
America where they and it belongs
working hard on the trade bills but if
Democrats gain power they will try to
reverse these incredible gains these are
historic gains they will try and reverse
many of them so your vote in 2018 is
every bit as important as your vote in
2016
although I'm not sure I really believe
that but you know I don't know who the
hell wrote that line I'm not sure but
it's still important to remember that's
why we will be campaigning for every
last vote in every part of our great
country we will be campaigning for the
votes of all Americans whether they're
registered as Democrats and we got a lot
of Democrats voting for us as you know
in 16 a lot they couldn't believe it
they could not believe it
we got a lot of Barack Obama voters
voting for us we got a lot of Bernie
Sanders voting for us can you believe it
mostly people that didn't like get
getting ripped off on trade Bernie
Sanders voters he was right about that
but he wasn't able to do anything about
it
these are people that want a government
that protects faith family and life
to support Republican candidates I have
helped raise a record-breaking 175
million dollars for the Republican
National Committee
nobody has ever been close and as part
of our unprecedented effort our great
Vice President a true leader in the
pro-life movement mike has been a true
leader has been working to elect more
and more Republicans we will be
appealing to voters all across America
who previously sent a Democrat to
Washington only to discover they elected
a proxy vote for Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi these are people that don't
believe in borders don't believe in
fighting crime don't believe in making a
strong military they don't believe in
what the people in this room believe
that I can tell you so we have to do a
great job if Democrats ever gained power
they were try to put up the taxes so
many things open those borders they
don't want walls they don't want people
stopping and the other day just the
other day Nancy Pelosi came out in favor
of ms-13 that's the first time I've
heard that she wants them to be treated
with respect as two other Democrats
that's not going to be happening we're
not going to release violent criminals
into our country
we're going to shut down everything we
have to shut down and we're going to
open up the great American energy we are
going to open up our energy and in all
fairness that's already happened we are
now
net exporter of energy for the first
time and we all know what a Democratic
majority would mean especially for the
people in this room
on the Supreme Court these are the
stakes on election day and this is why
you need to fight for victory in
November we can't be complacent what
happens historically a tremendous
percentage of the time you win the
presidential election you become
complacent you happy oh we won isn't it
wonderful then you have another election
comes up pretty quickly two years all of
these congressmen can tell you see the
senators they like they like their term
a little bit better how about changing
some of them to two years - I don't
think it's gonna be that would be a
tough vote in the Senate wouldn't it but
all of a sudden you come up again and
they get complacent they say hello we
just won so we sit back the other side
has energy and they win it's a
tremendous percentage of the time I
honestly don't believe that's going to
happen this time and it's starting to
show up in the polls
really don't believe it every values
voter must be energized mobilized and
engaged you have to get out there
this organization bears the name of one
of the greatest champions of freedom in
American history susan b anthony
she fought for decades to end slavery to
secure women's right to vote and to
respect the dignity of every single
person a great person a great woman was
she now we have a chance to honor her
legacy and restore the first write in
the Declaration of Independence it's
called the right to life here with us
this evening our Lisa and Bruce
Alexander and their family from
Gaithersburg Maryland good place in
January of 2012 the Alexander's attended
the March for life and God put it in
their hearts to adopt a beautiful child
two years later in January of 2014 the
Alexander's got a call that a baby had
been born who was opioid-dependent she
desperately needed a loving home she was
in serious serious trouble and the
Alexander's welcomed her into their home
with wide open arms
after the baby was treated for opioid
withdrawal they brought home their new
and very beautiful daughter Catherine hi
Catherine hi
come on up here castle coming
Catherines four years old and she is
full of incredible energy spirit and
talent at the age of two come on up
Catherine she memorized America the
Beautiful she recites poetry and
recently she announced to her dead that
when she grows up she wants to be a
famous police officer and then when she
gets tired of that she wants to become
president that's okay
[Applause]
she'll be President someday every time
Catherine's older siblings come home
from school Catherine runs into their
arms and gives them a great big
beautiful hug they're amazed by how much
she loves them and how much they love
her so tonight we celebrate you
Catherine we celebrate your life thank
you darling
and we celebrate our lives we celebrate
the loving choice of adoption Catherine
reminds us that every life is sacred and
that every child is a precious gift from
God so true
as the Lord says in Jeremiah before I
formed you in the womb I knew you before
you were born I set you apart when a
mother and a father hold a new baby in
their arms they are changed forever when
a child says mommy or daddy for the
first time there's nothing like it
anywhere in the world no matter what you
do there is nothing like it and when
parents watch their children thrive and
grow they're filled with a joy beyond
words and a love beyond measure you know
that everybody in this room when we look
into the eyes of a newborn child there
is no doubt we see the beauty of the
human soul and the mystery of God's
great creation we know that every life
has meaning and that every life is
totally worth protecting
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much when we stand for
life we stand for the true source of
America's greatness it's our people our
people are great it's the people who
grace our lives who sustain our
communities and who make America a
nation a home and this magnificent land
that we all love so much as long as we
have faith in our citizens confidence in
our values and trust in our God then we
will never ever fail
[Applause]
our nation will thrive our people will
prosper and America will be greater than
ever before and that's what's happening
so this November vote for family vote
for love vote for faith and values vote
for country and vote for life
I want to just end by thanking the susan
b anthony list you are very very special
people is a great honor for me to be
here tonight thank you everyone thank
you to life and liberty god bless you
and God bless america thank you very
much thank you